welcome everyone I've I've been notified
that this is the last session before
lunch so you know um I'll try to keep it
short so everyone can be in line first
um this is going to be about done at
Maui and Blazer
um so we're going to see a little bit
about how that all mixes together who
already worked with examine forms
okay okay Donna Maui yes all right
Blazer
oh much laser okay okay then I'll I'll
go into a little bit more Don and Maui
maybe we'll see we'll see how it goes
um typically I don't know how it happens
at NDC because we're being live streamed
and recorded So hello people at home
um if you have any questions come to the
microphone I don't mind being
interrupted or anything so if you have
something just come up here I'll ignore
you for a little while and then I'll
answer your question so who even am I
um my name is Gerald I work at Microsoft
I could still log in this morning so
apparently I still have a job
um and you can also find me on Twitter
for now which is you know also something
that's ongoing but if you have any
questions or anything after this I'll
not be around for too long today
unfortunately
um I'll be around probably for for a
good amount of time for this day but
elsewhere you can find me on Twitter
um send me a message through email I
also do a little thing on YouTube where
I also talk about that at Maui and
Blazer and some other stuff as well so
if that's something that you like then
um ding that Bell And subscribe and do
all the things that other YouTubers are
asking you to do so for the agenda today
um it's actually pretty simple it's
gonna be what is done at memory Blazer
but there's a couple of things in you
right we have what is Dan and Maui
basically so we're going to see a little
bit about that
um what is Blazer well a lot of people
already knew what Blazer is have worked
with it so that's probably going to be a
short little thing
um and then we have of course like what
is done at Maui and Blazer together what
can that do
um so let's start with what is done and
Maui well if you want to put it very
simply
um it is the evolution of xamarin forms
so examine forms has been our offering
for creating cross-platform apps with
c-sharp and Dot net and you could write
ads for iOS Android uwp uwp sadly no
longer with us we're not supporting that
anymore and then under the little second
line there we have tizen Linux WPF and
Mac OS so at this time for the people
who are wondering who still have xamarin
forms apps that they need to support we
have support until May 2024 for example
in forms so you know we will make sure
that it keeps working for you that you
can keep your app in production but I
would advise to transition to Dan and
Rari as fast as possible but you know
you don't need to worry you don't need
to do it this week but somewhere between
now and the next 16 months would be good
but you know xamarin forms also it
already has kind of I don't know if this
story is true what I like to think it is
so it already has kind of like a boring
name examine forms right it's not really
nice
um so and someone told me like xamarin
forms was also kind of like designed
with that in mind like also I dug up
this this with the Wayback machine this
graphic from
um the website I think xamarin wasn't
even acquired by Microsoft I'm not
really sure um from the website and it
has this right it doesn't even really
matter what what it all says here
um but it just says examine forms is
best for and then you can see the
screenshot with gray boxes and a blue
box
um and but if you really want to get the
power then you need to do examine iOS
examiner in Android that's the layer
below that right we'll get into how that
all fits together in a little bit but
then you can suddenly create media
players and games and do things with
maps
um applications always looks better with
maps in them I don't know why that is
but it does just does
um so it already was kind of like
marketed as a boring thing that image
also already always stuck with us but
you definitely could do more and maybe
it was architected with these kinds of
apps in mind right data entry not too
fancy applications but you could
definitely do that so the way xamarin
forms works is based on renders so if
you want to put that very simply we
created an abstraction layer where you
could say hey I want to have a button or
a label and then you have a bunch of
properties that you can set on that and
what we are doing with xamarin forms is
transforming those properties to
whatever that should be on iOS or
Android or whatever the platform is that
you're running on right it's a little
bit more complicated than that but very
simply but that's what we do so
we architected that um with all this in
mind but you could also write custom
renderers so you could also start
connecting your own properties and you
could leverage everything on the
platform because on that xamarin iOS
examine Android layer you would have all
the power of that platform you could
still write it with c-sharpin.net but
not everything necessarily was serviced
in that examin forms abstraction layer
but you could still access it so people
were doing that and people were creating
games I have a person here with a
wonderful I should have included a slide
with other sessions about Maui I was
going to do that but there are other
sessions about Maui this gentleman here
Sean is going to talk about creating
games with that in Maui so that's going
to be amazing so people were creating
games with this people were creating all
kinds of awesome apps with this and then
it kind of came to show that the way it
was architected wasn't maybe really
optimal for all of that so maybe the
story is a little bit true but luckily
now we've taken that six seven eight
years of xamarin forms knowledge and
everything that was good and everything
that was also not so good and we've
um put that in done at Maui Donald Maui
stands for multi-platform app UI now the
P we've made that conveniently lowercase
because down in the power it's just a
little bit different right
um so Dan and Maui is just sounds a
little bit better
um and now this is our cross-platform
app based on c-sharpon.net still of
course and now we can build for iOS
Android Windows and Mac OS so you can
see uwp is gone we're not going to make
the same mistake in called the win UI
and maybe that will change in the future
so we're just going to call it Windows
now and Mac OS also got bumped up to
like the big line and actually is a
first-class citizen that we're
supporting so there's a new focus a big
focus on desktop apps as well there's a
couple of spots here in the oh you have
seats okay that's fine
um
and also I I didn't I still I get always
the
um comment here from another gentleman
and we're all friends here that Tyson is
not on here so Tyson is also that's a
platform from Samsung
um it runs on like watches and all kinds
of crazy stuff even your fridge at home
so you can run down at Maui apps earlier
today we have someone from tizen um they
took a game from Sean here put it on a
fridge so you could play a game with Don
and Maui on your fridge it's a crazy
crazy world welcome to 2023. so Don and
Maui if we put that in a little
marketing sauce one sentence Dan and
Maui is the most productive way to
develop native apps that perform great
on any device which runs on Android iOS
Mac OS and windows from a single copies
and that single code base is now more
true than ever we'll see that in a
little bit before we go in there let me
explain a little bit more how all the
layers and things work together now for
Don and Maui but it's mostly the same
also how it worked for examine forms um
so this is the thing that you want to
focus on right you have this idea you
have that that million dollar dollar
idea that's going to make you rich and
you don't have to go to these
conferences anymore you can just you
know I don't know what millionaires do
but you can definitely do that and
that's your app idea right this is your
business logic this is where you want to
be productive this is where you want to
spend your time not with tooling and all
kinds of other stuff this is what you
want to do and if you want to build that
app for Android iOS Mac OS Windows
you're going to have to build that app
like three four times depending on which
route you take exactly and then if
you're going to go with like the native
Stacks then you have to learn Java or
kotlin or objective c or Swift maybe and
of course C sharpen.net which is amazing
right so we're already good there for
the windows part so but how do you get
from all these sdks these separate sdks
and building that same app basically
four times
um to just focusing on your app code
most of the time right there is a bunch
of layers and we're taking care of that
for you so that's the good news you can
just know that it's there if you're
going to do some more advanced stuff
you're probably going to run into one of
these layers as well but mostly our goal
is to not have you really worry about
this too much but it's still good to
know so the first layer is the.net
runtime technically if you're going to
look into the specifics this is still
running except for Windows on the mono
framework
excuse me so Mano is the open source
implementation of the.net framework
basically right
um so that's still running on on
everything
except for Windows but now it's just you
know incorporated into the download
runtime and you don't need to worry
about any of that anymore so on top of
that we have the data base class Library
that's basically what your all
programming against all the time anyway
and since.net6 so since November last
year or the year before that
um we've unified all that and that will
figure out on which dot net runtime is
running and you don't need to worry
about any of that that's a unified thing
so for all the platforms you're now
programming against that thing then on
top of that we have.net for android.net
for iOS and win UI I already mentioned
with UI right so what that Maui is doing
we're building this abstraction layer on
top of all these Technologies and done
it for android.net for iOS was before
examin.androidexamarin.ios
but now
um we're rebranding that basically to
download for android.net for iOS which
is mostly a marketing thing because if
you're going to you can still build apps
with on that layer if that's what you
want and do not use that in Maui um
all together but all the namespaces and
all the types there I'll show you that
in a little bit when we get to the demo
it's just names that come from the iOS
and the Android ecosystem so nothing
much changes except for the marketing
name basically so that's great and on
top of that we're building gun and
powering right we have that in the power
and that allows you to also share all of
your UI code with example with code
whatever you want
um and that will translate through all
the layers to building an app with
c-sharp and Dot net and deploying it to
all the platforms that we see here
now because of all that history with
xamarin forms we already have a big
library with all kinds of controls and
this is still talking about like the
native apps right we'll get to Blazer in
a little bit that's what you're here for
I know I'll lure you in here a little
bit
um but we already have a rich set of
controls also for Don and Maui and the
cool thing is together with blazer we
can mix and match those things as well
so that's why I'm telling you all this
so we already have 40 plus controls all
kinds of types of navigation with
hamburger menus
um top Taps bottom Taps all the tabs
that you want you can build your own of
course if that's what you need we have
adaptive layout so what I said we have a
new focus on desktop
um I'll be honest for especially if
you're going to build native apps it
will take some tweaking
um to you know make it look nice and and
work nice on a desktop and mobile but we
have all the Adaptive layouts that you
need to scale it automatically so that
you don't have a basically a stretched
out version of your mobile phone your
mobile app whenever you're running on
Windows nobody likes that
um so we have all of that right to left
and maybe most importantly also we have
accessibility a new focus on
accessibility we're constantly working
with accessibility teams on um within
Microsoft and kind of like Benchmark our
application how we're doing for
accessibility because if we make it
easier for you to create accessible apps
then there will be more accessible apps
and everyone wins right because people
who need that will be very thankful with
that
um if we run then a little sample with
all the controls this is kind of like
what it looks like so we have all the
basic controls that you would expect
sliders images buttons check boxes radio
buttons
um you name it we have it basically I
just released the other day we have a
little Community toolkit that also works
on Don and Maui where we have the media
elements you can also play videos audio
with that so we have all kinds of cool
stuff
now what does that look like if you've
been working with Microsoft Technologies
before then this should look pretty
familiar we have xaml so we've known
that for a long long time we of course
we renamed a couple of properties and
things just so that you not know what
all the properties are named now that
kind of comes from the the xamarin forms
world where
um the names I don't know they match
more with like the mobile Paradigm I
think so we have yet another dialect
unfortunately but that's unfortunately
how it is but all the example stuff
still work so it should look familiar
all the things for mvdm is built in so
we have data binding you can very easily
do that if you already know that from
other.net projects then you will feel
right at home basically we also have
some
Alternatives so what we're seeing much
much more is also people who want to do
their UI in C sharp so you can
definitely do that we have one solution
also in that Community toolkit also
available for examine if that's what
you're still doing which is called the
c-sharp markup extensions which
basically allows you to fluently write
your uis also in c-sharp people prefer
that people love xaml so choose whatever
you want and another thing that we're
exploring is called comet in our world
which is more a mvu so that's basically
replacing the whole mpvm pattern as a
whole and doing some different things
with with building up your UI mvu that
you might know from like Swift UI or
jetpack compose or pet flutter
um so you know it's just something that
we're that we're exploring it's
experimental for now but if that's
something that you're interested in go
use it just search done at Maui Comet
and you will find it it's it's still
pretty active so the more we see there
the more we can explore there now I said
from a single co-pay so we also made a
lot of improvements in our project
system so I'll quickly go over it we'll
see that in the demo more extensively so
this is a typical examin form setup
right at the very top level this is
Visual Studio for Mac by the way if this
doesn't look familiar so at the very top
we have the solution which is called my
app and then you have another my app
which is the shared dll so the shared
code and everything that you put in
there will be shared across the platform
right that's how it was for example in
forms you want to have your example
pages in there you want to have your
logic basically in there of course you
can still you know create more dlls and
that will all be shared but this is how
it would typically look like and then
you would have basically project heads
for each platform and if you think about
how this works that makes sense right so
we have this Android and iOS and if you
would support Windows or tizen or
whatnot you would have multiple projects
doing that which makes sense at the end
of the day we still have to deliver
binaries that Android and and iOS
understand right they're not going to
say like oh yeah send an XE we'll just
make sure it works they're not going to
do that so we still need to deliver an
aab file for for Android and an IPA file
for iOS and from from that perspective
it makes sense you still need to provide
all kinds of metadata all kinds of
resources images in gazillion formats so
you know we would have like these these
project hats that would build the binary
for each platform but for a developer
that's not great because all those
resources you now have to duplicate you
now have to do duplicate effort for
Android for iOS for Windows for all the
platforms that you want to support so
that's why we came up with the signal
project approach which is based on
multi-targeting and basically now we
have this this little folder that's
called platforms and inside of that you
will still have all the power to write
platform specific code so if you go into
that platforms it will be a little bit
dangerous it will be a little bit scary
because there you'll get into IOS
namespaces and Android namespace but
it's also very powerful because we have
wrappers for all the apis on those
platforms and you can leverage them from
there and it's very easy to use now
because everything outside of that
platforms folder is shared code so if
you wrap something in like a little
dependency injection or something you
can just use that code inside of that
platforms thing write platform specific
code and then outside of it you can just
use it in your shared code very very
easy and also same thing for the
resources we can now just add fonts we
typically you would add the fonts to all
the projects and duplicate all of that
the images same thing like I said for
iOS it's well we're getting more form
factors there as well so you need to
duplicate a lot of effort there but it's
still kind of like three skill factors
so for each image you have to add it
like three times but for Android it's
nuts right we have all these kinds of
Android variations and and form factors
and you can run it on your fridge and on
your I don't know what I ran it on the
TV ones which was fun
um so you have to do all these scale
things and we do that now for you so
ideally you put an SVG in there because
that skills with infinity in back and
then we do the scaling and compile time
to all the formats for all the platforms
that you're trying to Target here so
that's the things that we do with the
single project which will make your life
easier and we will worry about how that
ends up in the binaries for IOS and
Android so how does it know what to
build for well you just go to the Run
menu in Visual Studio you select David's
iPhone that's a bit weird if you see
David's iPhone on your machine then
something is wrong but you will see your
devices there whatever you've connected
and you can just then select hey I want
to build for Android for iOS for Windows
we will figure out the bits that we need
to take for those platforms and it will
start running so if you've been coming
from the examin world then you also
might still know about Essentials
those were a bunch of apis that were
common across platforms right but not
necessarily have any UI but you could
access your GPS sensor get the location
do your flashlight maybe you could set
your ringtone to silent that's all apis
that we have here
um
okay maybe not that last one no worries
so you could get better information you
can get all kinds of stuff right and and
those apis are now just part of Dan and
Maui I still keep referring to them as
Essentials but now they just live in
Microsoft and maui.devices or something
I think most of the time and you can get
all the information from a device but
it's still very easy especially for the
transition scenario to refer to them as
Essentials but all the apis are mostly
still the same and I mentioned that
because you can also leverage all of
that in Blazer we'll get to that in a
little bit let's quickly go over a demo
for the whole dynamic Maui stuff
um so if you've never done anything
before Oh this is kind of small now
because I filled with the resolution so
sorry about that but if you've never
done anything before and you're just
getting started with this you can do
everything for free you can just get the
visual studio Community Edition if
that's what you want to try it out
um so you will get to the installer this
is also what you'll see but this will be
empty here whenever you you get to the
installer and you'll get a screen like
this doesn't really matter which one I
choose you'll get a screen like this
where you want to choose whatever you're
going to install and you have the
components here with with.net Maui as
well right so we have this.net Maui
thing here just make sure this is
checked and this will install everything
on your machine that is needed to get
started with done it now right now
obviously I've already done that we're
not going to watch an installer that
would be a boring session
um so I have Visual Studio already here
I did zoom in this one a little bit so
that's not a new feature of Visual
Studio it doesn't look suddenly not that
nice that's just because I scaled
everything and whenever you do start
Visual Studio 2022 you can create a new
project and now you will see a couple of
new templates I also don't have them
here already in the recent templates so
you can see a.net Maui app a.net Maui
Blazer app
and you can also search here you would
have a Maui class Library which is
basically a typical class library but
now it already has some bits on board
that will help you Target only windows
or only Android or whatnot so we could
look into that but let's just stick with
the apps for now so if you do that we're
going to click next Maui app 13 I think
that's the one that's good to make me
Rich so sounds good and then you can
choose like which framework right I
think the official support policy is for
dotted Maui specific is a little bit
different than net as a whole so the
long-term support version isn't really
applicable to done in Maui so typically
what you want to do is just get on the
latest.net for your dining Maui
application that will get you all the
latest goodies and whenever you do it
will generate something like this
um you can see again example
um content page so you can see all these
abstractions right content space cool
view whenever things get out of the
viewport make sure that you can scroll a
vertical stack layout which Stacks all
the controls vertically you have a
little image a label a button so a
couple of things that you can do and
like any file new template within.net
there has to be something to increment
so whenever you click it it will do a
little counter right so whenever we run
this on Android let me just start that
already because sometimes it will take a
little bit of time to do that first
deploy oh it's pretty quick today so
that's good
um
you will see a little.net bond that's
waving at you feel free to wave back it
doesn't matter
um and we have hello world and welcome
and we can increment this little button
right so that's all generated whenever I
stop this and I say hey I want to run
this on Windows now I can just switch
over to Windows I can run it again and
we should see a pretty similar
application but now running as a with UI
application without changing anything
basically and now you can deploy it as a
Windows app and run it like that and we
also have like all the cool things here
um
we have um the the older hot reloads the
example hot reload.net Hub reload um so
you can do all of that as well so you
can run this on Windows and we have this
live previewer if you're on a single
monitor or like I am right now and you
can't have all the windows side by side
we have this live previewer
um so you can see here what's going on
with everything that you're doing
whenever you put that here side by side
um let me pin this here
then you can change all the things so
this is the example how to reload if I
say hey this button well that should be
background I'm not the greatest designer
you'll figure that out in my slides as
well
um red save that you can see it
immediately turns red right so this
especially if you're working with IOS
and Android the deployment time can be a
bit long
um so this makes it easier to not have
to restart whenever you just want to
change a color and see how that looks
and wait minutes before that actually
happens and dotnet hard reload is even
cooler where you can just say hey I want
to go into the code and this is still
running I'm still in my debug session I
can say hey this is now plus is I don't
know one three three seven let's make it
something cool I think I need to click
the flame you can configure it to do it
on Save and now whenever I do this it's
going to count much faster right so it's
applying those code changes while I'm
actually running so I don't even need to
restart my debugging session here very
cool
um let's have a quick look at the
project here so um here you can see all
the things from that single project
approach so we have these platforms here
Android ties and iOS all the platforms
that we support
um and if we go into I don't know
because iOS one we still have a info p
list that actually contains all the
metadata that is needed for like the App
Store and what the name looks like on
your home screen that kind of stuff we
still need that so that's in this this
convenient little folder and whenever
you go to the app delegate which is kind
of like your your entry point uh well
actually it's the other one but your
entry point for an iOS application then
you can see we are hooking everything up
for you right but you also see that we
are using somebody using Foundation
what's that that's a iOS namespace right
so I can suddenly create all this iOS
stuff here but it's still C sharpen.net
I can wrap this in an interface I can
register that in my dependency injection
and suddenly you can leverage all the
power of that platform through your.net
Valley app so even if we didn't service
something in done and Maui you can still
enable that yourself
um speaking of the dependency injection
so we have that built in so if you do
not have any experience with
cross-platform development yet
um you're in for fun it's going to be
hard I'm not gonna lie it's going to be
hard there's a lot to know right even as
much as we try to make it easier for you
um it you'll run into a point where you
want to do something Advanced and it's
going to hurt a little bit
um you're going to ask yourself why am I
doing this no I'm kidding but you're
going to run into like you have to need
to know a little bit about the
underlying systems but everything that
we can do to kind of like lower that
threshold to get you started quicker and
easier
um that's what we're trying to do also
with like all this stuff so we adopted
kind of like the pattern of asp.net
um where they have like this this app
builder the generic build host where you
can hook up all the services
um so we kind of adopted that with this
as well so we have this Maui program
where you can create that Builder use
Maui Apple you have to do that to bring
in all the Maui stuff and register this
as an entry point for your app configure
font so we need that if we want to do
custom fonts
um but we can also so we have already
this Builder logging at debug but you
can also say like hey um Builder Dot
Services I'm really bad at typing in
front of audiences which is funny if
you're a public speaker but anyway
um so you have at Singleton right so I
can add do this ad Singleton here and I
can just register these things and you
can also of course um add your own
interface here I I don't know green card
in Bowl I don't know maybe you want to
put a green card in a bowl for some
reason I don't know
um the signal right so you can register
that and then you can just inject it the
way that you're used to from maybe other
net projects so we're trying to make
this as much familiar as possible so
that you kind of recognize this if
you've never worked with cross-platform
house before and you're like oh I
recognize this I kind of know how to
work with this so that is pretty nice I
think I've said everything I wanted to
say about this
um yeah so let's move on to the next
part
which is then about Blazer yay finally
but everyone already to do about Blaze
who doesn't know about Blazer
yes this is for you fine sir
um what is Blazer so Blazer is a web
development without JavaScript well
that's it uh no so I I of course this is
always the the unique selling point
right but um you have all these these
rich applications these rich web
applications single page applications
um with all these kinds of cool things
so if you go there in the browser you
have the sidebar with all kinds of
options you have alerts you have grids
you have all kinds of cool stuff um and
then whenever you go to that same
application in your mobile device then
it all scales and it still works and it
still looks nice but if you think about
these applications and you automatically
think about JavaScript Frameworks right
this is all built on top of angular
react view which is all based on
JavaScript now I can make jokes about
JavaScript all day here but in that time
5 000 new JavaScript Frameworks will
have come out so I'm not going to view
that
um but so wouldn't it be cool I can
there's some truth like I like to kid
about JavaScript obviously
um but this could be true for any
language right whenever I have to deal
with this type of uh project
um it's just about switching context
right it could also be typescript which
is already better it could also be I
don't know what else is hip these days
um but whatever you have to switch const
context between languages that's just
going to eat into your productivity I
always have to look up like oh yes how
is that jQuery stuff work I think people
are laughing out when you say jQuery you
shouldn't be using that but oh how does
that work right how does CSS work how
does html work whenever you have to
switch that context it's going to eat
into your productivity so how cool would
it be if we could do all of that
um still with.net still with c-sharp
still with all the stuff that you're
used to um if you're a c-sharp and Dot
net developer so you will have the C
sharp language you don't never have to
leave it
um there's definitely something you can
still leave it if you want kind of like
the same with the cross-platform stuff
you can still go out and Leverage The
Power of JavaScript because that's what
you want but you don't have to you
necessarily don't have to so you can
still use the tooling the IDE that's
there you can use Visual Studio Visual
Studio code if that's what you want
you'll still have that consistent
ecosystem you don't have to download
half of the internet with npm packages
you can just download a quarter of the
internet with nuket packages and we'll
have that stability right you can build
on top of uh I don't know 20 years
of.net we've just celebrated 20 years I
think so there's a lot of stability a
lot of history and you can build on top
of that so it's part of the asp.net CORE
family so where does it fit in it's not
going to be a surprise it fits into that
box that wasn't there so we now have MVC
razor Pages was already there right
single page applications we already had
templates for that I think it was
actually built on angular that's not
going away but now we also have Blazer
right you can do that as well and then
on the services side which is basically
all the asp.net offerings we have
without any UI so you can do your rest
apis you can do grpc signalr which is
also fun to use in this
um context as well but we have all of
that so how does it actually work we
have two options for using Blazer
applications
um kind of like your more traditional
one where you just have a server still
but it runs as a Blazer application on
that server and then through a signalr
connection it will actually go back and
forth because you have a single page
application so not everything is loaded
each time only
um pieces inside of your document object
model the Dom is going to be replaced
and that's going to go back and forth to
that server so that's not really
effective but it definitely has its its
use cases right but that's your more
typical scenario the important thing is
that it runs on within asp.net core then
we have that laser stack and then we
have that Blazer components I'm probably
going to say Blazer components a lot in
the upcoming time that you'll get bored
so raise your hand if I say it too much
no not yet all right so the Blazer
components razor components is going to
be an important thing that I'm going to
mention a couple of times and then you
can still run it like this but we also
have Blazer webassembly which is really
cool
um which is actually really the power of
laser right webassembly is not something
that we've invented um that's a
technology that allows you to run
everything inside of your browser and
not just JavaScript right that's the
thing that we know but with webassembly
um you compile it to an intermediate
language that can be run inside of your
browse and you can write a compiler for
your own programming language if that's
what you have I think you can do it for
C plus plus for rust and now for C sharp
that's basically how Blazer uh kind of
like started so we still have that same
stack but now the whole thing is
downloaded inside of your browser
including the.net version right because
the.net framework that's installed as a
whole thing on your machine we're not
going to do that anymore so what we're
going to have to do is also download
the.net um framework version for your
application I think as of.net6 and
probably.net7 did it even better but I
know the number 4.net6 it's just you
know one megabyte for the whole.net
framework I think so that's you know
smaller than your regular cat gif that
you you're watching
um but still something to be mindful of
right when you're choosing the right
option here and then you can just
communicate with the document object
model and replace all the things
um while you're inside of the browser
but you have to be aware that basically
all your code although in in binary form
is being downloaded to the browser so
whenever we have options we have kind of
like pros and cons I'm not going to read
them all to you I think the important
bits are at the bottom which is kind of
like in the cons like if you're doing
Blazer server then you have like you
have to have a constant connection
because all the changes are going back
and forth
um obviously also because of that you're
gonna have that higher UI latency and
for the Blazer web assembly it's going
to be faster you don't need a persistent
connection only to download the
application one time but you're gonna
have a larger download size initially
and you know the runtime performance
isn't really predictable because you
don't have a beefy server on one end it
can be a Thin Client or whatnot you
don't really know so um there's all that
so now we have server webassembly and
the next thing we're going to look at in
a little bit is hybrid so that's the
third option that we're going to add to
all of this goodness how am I doing for
time well I think we're okay oh my gosh
is this someone else oh it's you oh no
all right so if we did it again I'm just
gonna quickly run through this
um
and you'll see in a little bit wide just
so we can make the comparison between
the project types so if I'm closing this
um very revolutionary Maui app 12.
how am I going to do that close solution
there we are
um
and I start another project then we can
search for Blazer right it's kind of
ironic that angular and if you are at
the top now but I'm going to search for
Blazer and whoops
there we go so and then you can choose a
couple of options right we have Blazer
server Blaze webassembly we have
completely empty templates that's
something that some people like as well
um but you can we can just get one of
those and I'm gonna get with the server
one you can very easily transition
between webassembly and server if that's
what you want or relatively easy at
least laser app seven
this is not the alarm right I've heard
the reputation with NBC and fire alarms
but this is not one right
um you can again choose a framework
authentication type so you can set up
authentication immediately as well with
some kind of social provider configure
HTTP as well we're not animals so we're
going to definitely do that and I don't
know anything about Docker so I'm going
to skip that click create is going to
think a little bit and then it's going
to come up with the template for
Blazer and if we look at that then you
know if we just dive straight into that
program they applied like the uh what is
it I don't know what the correct term is
but anyway they left out like all the
the ceremony here so no name spaces and
whatnot we didn't do that for Don and
Mao yet so that's why this looks a
little bit different but we still
recognize these things right we have
this create Builder right here and we
can add the services we need to add the
ranger pages and server-side Laser to
make the Blazer stuff work a Singleton
for our weather forecast service so we
can register all the things and this
looks very similar to whatever you know
from net
so this looks different
what does this do
so whenever I run this we'll get a
Blazer application which you probably
have seen once you can see like the
Blazer server so we get a little
terminal thingy that's going on here
which is going to act as our server and
then it's going to listen for requests
and then we have our Blazer application
Well normally there's Applause here but
no worries
um so we have this hello world and
actually this little gray box here
um that is how is Blazer working for you
that is a Blazer component so again I'm
gonna get back to that in a little bit
uh we have this counter because what's a
file new application without a counter
right so this still works um and we have
this fetch data where it kind of
simulates getting data from a remote
service so we have this this Blazer
application that's going on but more
interesting is for me at this point the
project setup here as well so you can
see it's it's a little bit different if
you're coming from a web World it
probably will look familiar so you have
this www root for the static files for
your CSS and the images
um we have these Razer Pages we have the
pages that we're actually going to so we
have this index and then if you know a
little bit about Blazer you can see that
we have this ad page slash right so we
have this little slash and that
registers um what where the pages can be
reached so if we go to another page we
can go to slash whatever fetch data I
mean you can see that add slash fetch
data and that's the endpoint where
you're going to reach that page now I'm
not gonna well no I'm gonna wait for
another demo to go into all of this
which you can see here so this is all
Blazer syntax you can just mix the HTML
kind of like in your PHP or asp.net web
forms days you can mix all these things
right here and you can have these code
blocks if you really want to you can
just create a in this case a fetch
data.razer you will create a
fetchdata.razer.cs it will automatically
know that these pages should be linked
up and um
um you can use it as a regular code
behind file right so that will make it a
little bit neater if that's what you
want
um but we could do all these cool things
also here this inject so this is the way
you can inject things from your
dependency injection uh container inside
of Razor pages and we'll see why that is
important whenever we get to the Dan and
Maui and Blazer part together and that's
kind of like the autonomy of your Blazer
application is there anything more I
wanted to add here yes we have here the
app.razer so this is a a special razor
page which is basically the router
object so this registers your whole
Blazer application it kind of scaffold
it so you can see like we have this
router and we specify an app assembly
this is the assembly that it's going to
scan for all those routes things that we
just saw on the pages so it's good to go
through that binary that assembly that
you specify here and then it's going to
go like okay I see an endpoint on slash
I see an endpoint on fetch data it's
going to register all these things and
it's going to know about it and then
whenever you navigate it's going to go
through here through the find and it's
going to wrap that in your default
layout right so you can specify a layout
that it will all fall into and you can
also have your not file so whenever the
user goes to a endpoint that doesn't
exist this is basically your HTTP 404
scenario right it's going to show you
this little thing here so all kinds of
options to configure that
um
and then whenever we have that we're
going to load that all in a nice little
pitch so that's kind of like in a
nutshell how Blazer works but now let's
see how that all works together which is
why we're actually here and finally
after
three quarters of a session we're
getting to it so done in Maui and Blazer
um basically The Best of Both Worlds and
I took a long time to make this
PowerPoint animation so we're gonna take
a minute to look at it
thank you thank you yes thank you
finally oh my gosh
this is where I get a class for okay
um
so with anime Blazer you can build
cross-platform native apps that run on
Windows Mac OS IOS and Android that's
not coincidentally all the platforms
that are supported by gun and memory
right
um You can totally do that and of course
you know if you set up your sharing
thing uh the right way you can also
share this across the web that's what
makes it really cool you can do that
with Razer components
um so right so that's the kind of like
the next one you can use your existing
Razer class libraries
um you don't need to change anything in
fact you can just take your third-party
Razer class libraries from a vendor if
that's what you want if you've bought
those
um you don't need to change anything
about them they don't even need to know
done and now it exists and you can just
put that in your Diamond Valley
application and they will just work so
that's really cool and you'll have full
platform device access I will get to
that in a little bit so Blazer hybrid is
kind of like the third option that I
already said next to Blazer server
Blazer webassembly it's built on top of
well.net6.net7 now and done at Maui and
it's implemented through a Blazer
webview control and that's kind of
important because that allows you to
also mix all this stuff so you can
actually you know in your native.net
Maui application
um you could just have one little blazer
webview component and you can load your
Blazer stuff in there and the rest will
be native so maybe you have one specific
need for a Blazer thingy
um or you know that's the kind of like
the default option you will just have
one big Blazer webview and you build
your whole app as a hybrid app right it
will just load your Blazer application
inside of a little wrapper container
inside of your mobile app but the Blazer
webview is also implemented for winforms
yes winforms is back
um and WPF so you can also do all this
inside of your WPF and winforms apps
they have to be upgraded to.net6 at
least 4.7 but you can then use a Blazer
webview inside of that and that's really
cool right because let's be honest you
have these conferences you have these
sessions and all the the cool people
um are going to be up here and talk
about the latest things and then
tomorrow you have to go back to the
office and you're gonna have to work on
that Legacy application right in
winforms so that's in reality
unfortunately for a lot of people
um well unfortunately I mean it's work
it's fine
um but you want to also use all this
this cool stuff and with this Blazer
webview that enables a whole new path of
like modernizing your winforms
application the big monolith that you
never have time or money for to rewrite
the whole thing with this Blazer webview
you can start kind of like modernizing
from inside out maybe build a Blazer
application next to it that you use here
those Razer web components with each
other so this enables all kinds of stuff
that how does that look like well the
Blazer webview you can just add it in
xaml you can add it in code if that's
what you want inside of your diet value
application and then you can see like
from this Blazer webview we have to
specify a host page where you know a
little bit of HTML lives that that wraps
the whole thing then this selector is an
HTML selector so that's the element
that's going to be used where your
Blazer application is going to be
injected basically and then we're going
to say hey what is going to be actually
ejected there and we're pointing to this
main object which then points to that in
this case it's called a main dot razor
probably because the name app was
already taken and then we have that
router thing again which looks almost
identical to whatever we've seen in
laser right so that's kind of like the
connection the bridge to your Blazer
application and from that point on you
can write and do all things Blazer if
that's what you want so before I dive
into the demo let's do a little blazer
hybrid MythBusters because a lot of the
questions that you then get is like hey
um do I need to is it going to mimic all
the things with a little server process
that's running on your application no
it's going to run 100 in one um process
because our Blazer application is
already running on.net right it doesn't
need to interpret JavaScript or do all
those things it's already done that it
runs AS a.net application and as we've
seen in the beginning of this session
um we already have the done at runtime
running
um on all these platforms right so we
can just go straight into the diamond
runtime and run that application as a
native application basically the only
thing that is rendered in uh so
basically the only thing that you're
doing is replacing that whole example
and and while it's still C sharp but
with HTML and CSS right so if you're
more of a web background and you still
want to build a native application
um this is a nice way to get started and
also like if you're starting with a
Blazer inside of a web browser you
luckily have a Sandbox right so if you
don't go to the if you go to a wrong
website on the Internet it's not going
to be able to format your hard drive
right but with a download Maui Blazer
application you can totally format your
hard drive so that's the good news no
but it isn't bound to those same
limitations it's loaded inside of a
webview but you can still go out to all
the essentials apis you can still get
the location you can still
um get all these things do the
flashlight
um do they access everything that's
available on those platforms so let's
see how that actually works I still have
some time so that's good
um
if we then start a next application
again
create a new one and now I'm going to go
with the.net blazer app we're gonna have
to do this same thing which is fine okay
and now you basically see the two
templates we've taken the dynamally
template we've taken the Blazer template
boom done in Maui Blaze ramp it's simple
as that
um so you can see these two templates
basically coming together so we still
have that Maui program we still see that
same bootstrapper and you can actually
see well we have to add this Blazer
webview so that it is utilizes there a
little bit but you can also see this at
Singleton weather forecast service that
we saw in our blender application right
so we can just register that in the same
way and we'll see in a little bit that
we can inject it in the razor in the
Blazer way right so there's you can mix
and match all of this stuff actually
while I'm talking let me deploy this to
Android because again that can take a
little bit of time sometimes so let me
start this while I'm talking here
um as you can see looking at the rest of
the project like we have both of these
things right so we have this this shared
with all the razor Pages we have the
actual pages with all the razor pages
but we also have this platforms folder
where you can all write your platform
specific code right so and you can
actually again it's getting boring I'm
getting repetitive you can write all
this this platform data that we've not
serviced to done at Maui you can reach
into this platforms something you can
use it now for brazer inside of this
mobile application so here in this main
page you can see that later webview
where we this is this is taking the
approach where we just make the
application one big web View and then
we're loading all the Razer Pages inside
of that so it's just one big Blazer
application but what you could also do
is make this hey I want to make this not
a Content page but I want to make this a
tabbed page which is a.net Maui thing
and now we can suddenly add all kinds of
children as separate tabs right so I'm
going to use the native platform tabs
and that look and feel but I'm actually
going to inside of the tab I can choose
for each one do I want to load a Blazer
webview inside of that with a Blazer
component in in that tab or in the other
tab I'm going to load the actual
platform with a camera view and do all
kinds of crazy stuff
so that's all options here that you can
kind of consider so if you want to do
that you can now say I think you have to
ramp it in a Content page I can give it
a title is index let's do that whoops
content page again I can't type under
pressure and why are you doing it I
don't know
ah
slash content page let's copy and paste
that it's not even working
so yeah I shouldn't go off script
cannot be assigned a following type was
expected I'm just going to roll with it
see what it does index what else do we
have the counter let's not forget the
counter
um and I can just add another one
and not do this Blazer web for you but
just add a
label text is I don't know think green I
don't know I have something with green
today maybe I don't know why
um so we could just have have this one
right so
evaluation something that comes to mind
so we have all these things I don't know
what this does for the oh it didn't pick
up on this so that's good so this is you
can see this is just the Blazer
application as well right
um and it actually we get all the
responsiveness all the responsive layout
stuff we get for free because bootstrap
is in here which is our web technology
which automatically picks up on
viewports and that kind of stuff so it
already folded everything inside of this
hamburger menu here we have the counter
which still works we have the fetch data
just like it worked in our Blazer server
application so we handle this this is
before the changes that I made here
while this was all deploying so if I now
stop and redeploy this again
um then we should see this kind of oh no
this is not gonna go right but we'll see
that in a little bit actually oh this is
always a fun one partial declaration
main page must not specify different
base classes so we have this tab page
right I've just changed this but xaml
always has a code behind a little Pro
tip right here
examples yes and now here it specifies a
Content page which is nonsense you don't
even need to specify this so problem
solved forever you're never going to see
that again
I still build errors oh no
um yeah I don't know something oh yeah
right so I now have two things that are
called Blazer webview
this is live debugging right here so
this is an ex name and now we have two
things that are called a Blazer webview
so that's not great
um while it's not building anyway I can
do the other thing that I needed to do
because we're loading here that complete
Blazer application right we're
injecting that main.razer which contains
the entire router
um but what you want to do now is only
load one page so what we want to do we
already have this local thing right
there I don't want to have the local we
want to have these Pages because we also
have these razor Pages here right we
have the index the fence data and the
counter and they all live in the pages
namespace so
what we want to do is go back here add a
new XML namespace for pages is Pages let
intellisense help me here thank you and
then I can just say not the local name
but I can just say pages
um index
or Pages oops
pages
and we're going to do here counter
and now just going to load that one page
inside of this tab hopefully whenever it
builds else I'm going to abandon shift
and move on oh no it works
um so now what we're going to see is the
native tabs for Android which you can
switch between here you can see it with
the index and the counter so we still
have this razor component here I
actually didn't go into that as much as
I told but we have this razor component
here
um you can go to this calendar still
works as expected and we have this
evaluation which is purple but it says
thing green
so you can mix all these things right
you can have these different tabs and
you can mix between Mao you can mix
between Blazer you can mix up all the
things depending on your needs which is
pretty cool that leaves me with 10
minutes for well one last demo so that's
cool
um which is a little bit of more
complete demo right which also shows you
uh how to escape that sandbox so
um
I have two young boys do we have any a
Falls
yes oh yes of course yes adult fans of
Lego Lego fans yes oh now there's more
people yeah yeah but you're not hardcore
enough if you don't know A4 okay
it doesn't matter so uh I have two young
boys I never really got that much into
Lego uh myself honestly but the two
young boys are getting into it so we now
have boxes full Lego
um and we were kind of like remodeling
our house so I wanted to know like okay
I I have these boxes of Lego I have all
this Lego how many boxes do I need to
actually move it from one place to
another to actually get it out of the
way so we can start building our house
right so I wrote this fantastic
application with a very impressive AI
algorithm to calculate all of this
um and I decided to build it a couple of
ways right so first
um we have a
um server one so this is just a Blazer
server application and whenever you load
it I like I said designing is not my
best you know
thing
um so you're gonna see the Blazer
application but the one thing that I can
do is graphical design so I added this
fantastic logo
feel free to applaud again doesn't
matter uh so I've added that one but
what it does is it takes you have to
cite a brick tracker so if you're into
Lego brick trackers like your your thing
um and you can go there and you can lock
all the collections that you have and it
will have all kinds of information about
the blocks like what color how they
smell how they taste I don't know all
that kind of stuff and you can export
CSV files with all the stuff that you
have right so you can take those CSV
files upload them here and then again my
AI algorithm will do all the things and
show you in how many boxes that's going
to fit now if you're going to do this
from a browser then um
you just can't go out to the file system
and get those CSV files right luckily
again for a browser you really have to
have that input thing where you specify
like hey this file is the one that you
can take other ones are off limits so we
have this file picker here let me just
go into here and actually get the
file path from here
um because I have a couple of those CSV
files here right so I go back to my
browser I have too many things open
copy that here and here I have a couple
of csvs again it's a little bit small
but there's two CSV files in here let's
take the Harry Potter one and let's go
to you know get all the Harry Potter
things that we have uh we can say
analyze and let's go to think for a
little bit analyzing Computing and it's
going to say boom we have 10 000 pieces
and you need two boxes to move it all
and it shows you which collections it is
exactly so that's kind of like how it
works okay so for a browser this is fine
right let's inspect how that works I'm
here for a little bit
um so we have this this Blazer server
project we've already seen the project
structure here and all the things are
happening in the index page because you
know who cares about clean code if it
works
um
and here I don't really have the nice
highlighting oh there we go so we have
this highlighting and here we have like
you can see this is not a HTML tag and
it's also not really like Blazer or or
example or whatnot but this is a a
um a helper thingy
um that allows you to hook up this this
input um onto a c-sharp method right so
we can say input file that will
translate into something HTML
understands so we get that file picker
thing but we can say on change and we
can here make the connection to load
files
um which uh then goes to this c-sharp
method that is right here and here we
can just write C sharp as if we were
real developers so we can get those
files you can get the the actual files
that are inputted here through the event
arcs we have this brick set collection
and then for each we're going to Loop
through them and we're going to load
those sets and we're going to actually
um show something with that right and
here it's actually pretty cool so we're
using this where is it collection
summary which is a
Razer component right thank you
um
and that is the cool thing we have this
component so I have separated that in
this this thing here which is just
another bunch of Cs files and Razer
files and you can just use that so here
we have this collection summary and
actually you know you can just have this
bunch of files and what makes it kind of
a component is that it's in a separate
dll you can distribute that for you
through nougat or something if that's
what you want but what makes it more
reusable is that you can add this
parameter to a c-sharp property and now
suddenly we can set this sets property
from outside right so we have this this
component and the naming of the
components is pretty easy we just have
collection summary.razer that will also
be the name of the component you can see
it here collection summary and we have
this sets property and what's really
cool is that you can not only pass
strings or simple types through these
properties but you can actually do this
set collection which is I don't know
what is it is a collection of brick set
collection which is a custom object that
we've created ourselves so you can just
pass that in to the components
um you can see my very impressive AI
algorithm here uh by the way it's uh IP
so don't copy it
um so we have got that going on this all
in inside of this component but now if I
run this uh same thing but this time I'm
going to do it for a diamond memory app
um
I'm going to switch to this Maui client
right here and let's run it on Windows
why not actually I made a difference
between the windows and the mobile
things as well I'm sure I might have
time to show it all to you but at least
I can show it in code so here it is
running on Windows which looks pretty
much as if you would run it inside of a
browser
um but you know it's it's still on
windows so you can still see here pretty
much like the responsiveness that you
kind of like get for free right that you
have to make some effort for that and
Maui to actually do that yourself
because if I go small enough here you
can see it automatically like folds
together right so that's the pretty cool
thing here
but here you can see we don't have a
button because on Windows you can format
your hard drive with down at Maui Blazer
right um but we what we can also do is
use the file system watches you might
know this those objects you can just
point to a location on your file system
and say Hey I want you to monitor this
and whenever changes happen you can hook
up the events whenever a file is created
or copied or renamed or do all kinds of
things so what I have here
um
is if I take the CSV files there are two
so let's just go wild and take these two
and I'm going to go to my downloads
folder because I set it to monitor my
downloads folder and I put it in here
then it does nothing
that wasn't supposed to happen
um
it does that sometimes but what it was
supposed to do is pick up on these file
chases in in the file system and load
those csvs and you can see that exact
same thing because we are using the
exact same razor component um also in
this done and Mario application I just
made a reference add that component in
here and boom it uses the same thing
um I think if I remove them again then
they will disappear so hopefully that
will work so the demo was saved a little
bit yes so you can see you can just
watch the file system but also again
this is still a done in Maui app and
this works very much on desktop but
accessing the file system like that on
Android or iOS that's not really a thing
so whenever you're going to run this on
Android again and again I'm not sure if
the deployments have been pretty good so
let's see if this one does that again
um
but here you have to introduce another
button again for like the mobile things
because you and then you can use those
Essentials apis we also have a file
system one
um where you can say hey I want to bring
up the file picker and then you could
still pick that's USB file but that also
connects again like the Blazer world
it's not building right now uh the
Blazer rule so you can do that HTML
thing but you can call a c-sharp API an
Essentials API actually get the native
file picker from there and transport
that file back to your Blazer world and
do the rest in your Blazer application
so just to show you how powerful this
all is now I'm going over time anyway so
let's do it properly I also hooked up a
little winforms application yes winforms
it's back it still exists it still has
the best designer
um
and it's still super fast so whenever
you still have that win forms
application
um you can just run that and you will
get the the typical gray Wind forms
looks right but it's still you know it
has something it's Charming uh so this
is basically how your your business line
application could look like and then
inside of this tab control we have this
analysis thing and I just you know
Googled with Bing for some
um components uh for a Blazer and I got
into the ratson components I think
they're free at least to some extent and
I could just load that inside of this
tab page now this is totally not hooked
up to all the Lego stuff but it's just
nice to show so this is what you're
seeing here is Blazer components from a
third-party vendor they might not even
know done and Maui exists
um you can well Orvin forms you can load
it inside of this winforms application
and suddenly you can do all these modern
things with like I don't know how many
steps you've taken with this winforms
app
um right so you can do all these cool
things and start replacing uh things
inside of your winform application all
right so let me quickly run through the
slides that we have left here there is a
very good real use case
um
that we are developing at Microsoft if
my slides continue to work
please oh there we go uh which is
the.net podcast
um it's a pretty much real world
application where you can listen to
podcasts together
um it has all the things it has an
architecture diagram all the code on
GitHub you can deploy it to Azure your
own Azure account don't forget to turn
it off whenever you're done ask me how I
know because it's going to burn through
a lot of credits very fast but you can
go through all these podcasts and listen
together there's a lot of signal R in
there and the cool thing is from the
diamond Maui and Blazer perspective they
built the app two times once with
dynamoe blazer so the entire app is
Blazer and it's actually sharing
components with the web application and
they've built it entirely native so with
all the xaml and that kind of stuff so
you can really see the differences
between those two clients and how you
would solve certain problems with
playing audio and all that kind of so
definitely go check that out now I can
see that you're barely sitting on your
season you're like yes I need to try
this out right now
um but please stay seated for a little
bit longer um is there anything else
before I let you explore on your own um
you can maybe see where kind of like the
slides that were designed for me stop
and where my design comes in so I get a
lot of these questions right like when
should I use that in Maui blazer because
there's a lot of options now or when or
should I use dotted value at all or you
know when should I use Blazer and the
answer to basically all of this is
it depends right or you could also say
it like yes use them all because that's
the nice thing right um it kind of
depends on your background if you're
using this in a business business
context like what are your requirements
what's your budget what's the knowledge
your team already has if you're a web
developer and you you want to get into
cross-platform development a little bit
more you can start with the diamond Maui
Blazer way or you have that existing
Blazer application and you want to
modernize this stuff and then there's a
path for you as well so and you know
just because you can and it's Saturday
and you have some time off and you like
to Tinker with all this stuff right
um if you want to put it in a little
graph
um if you want to choose an option for
reach like you can go to the web right
everything that runs a browser whether
it's your your refrigerator that's
always my favorite
um or whatever it is whenever you can
run in the browser use it probably go
with something that runs as a website a
progressive web app
um a Blazer application if you have some
situation where you're kind of like in
the middle
um you can go with electron native app
in a webview please don't do that
um or you can choose Blazer and Maui
that's kind of like why where we
position ourselves there and if you
really want to have the power in the
performance of the online platforms then
you should go with like the Frameworks
that are really using that power
directly so depending on what you're
building that can be of course Maui if
you want to go cross-platform it can be
win UI if you're only targeting windows
or winforms or WPF so definitely do that
oh I don't know how this got in here
okay so um we have a stand for Microsoft
on the fifth floor
um where you can win something so
um I think you can go to this URL or
scan this QR code
um you have to complete some modules
you'll learn something in return so
you're winning anyway you can win some
swag which is I've been told only for
people in the UK so sorry about that if
you're coming from abroad but you can
still I think everyone will get 50 of
the Microsoft exam voucher so that's
really cool as well we have a stand
upstairs they can tell it much better
than me probably so go check that out
thank you so much for joining I hope it
was informative or at least entertaining
and uh enjoy the rest of NDC I'll be
around for questions somewhere so thank
you foreign